avec vos julien shahida ce matin pour
julien bonjour vous revenez julien sur
l'utilisation de missiles hypersonique
dans la guerre en ukraine utilisation
reconnue par la russie ces jours ci et
qui fait craindre une escalade dans
l'utilisation de ce type d'armes
affectivement face à la résistance
ukrainienne le kremlin utilisent des
armes de plus en plus à l'écrit le
journal suisse le temps le quotidien
s'inquiète des fanfaronnades du
ministère de la défense ces derniers
jours qui a claironné à deux reprises
avoir utilisé donc pour la première fois
sur le terrain ses missiles hypersonique
c'est à dire qu en clair il est
impossible de les intercepter n'était
visé que des sites demande moindre
importance comme des sites de carburant
mais le journal dresse une liste
potentielle des armes potentiellement
non conventionnelles que pourraient
utiliser moscou on a déjà évoqué les
bombes à sous munitions des lancers par
human rights watch il était aussi
question de bombes au phosphore et
d'armes chimiques et biologiques bombes
au phosphore comme celles utilisées par
le régime syrien dans la boutargue
dentelle en 2013 régime soutenu par
moscou et d'après plusieurs experts
militaires l'utilisation éventuelle de
ces armes interdites par la convention
de genève de genève serait la
conséquence d'une opération militaire
russe qui n'avancerait pas comme prévu
oui les mots employés par l'opinion sont
même plus fort que ça on parle même
d'une déconvenue militaire et lorsqu'on
se présente comme l'une des armées les
plus puissantes au monde ça ne fait pas
très sérieux pour la russie des
centaines de milliards de dollars
dépensés en dix ans pour restructurer
tout le secteur militaire russe et pour
faire face à l'occident et résultats
pour l'instant c'est l'ukraine qui
résistent tant bien que mal comme elle
peut face à la russie le quotidien
évoque des défaillances de ses systèmes
de communication un manque de
préparation manque de motivation de
notre notamment de la part de certains
conscrits russes et peut-être d'après un
spécialiste du pentagone l'occident
avait t-il surestimé la puissance de feu
des russes eu égard aux déclarations
officielles du kremlin de quoi relancer
le rêve d' emmanuel macron de créer une
armée de défense à l'échelle européenne
on en est encore loin tempère le foreign
policy mais on y avance tout doucement
il ya déjà eu cette unité here pas une
retrouvés après le début de l'invasion
russe et l'instauration de sanctions
très forte contre moscou
la prochaine étape donc ce serait cette
nouvelle unité de défense militaire à
l'échelle européenne mais comment faire
c'est tout le problème puisque chaque
état membre a sa petite idée sur le coup
sur le comment mais aussi comment faire
pour garder la nuance militaire avec le
temps là toutes ces questions sont mises
sur la table interrogé par le magazine
américain un général italien explique
que la russie a ramené le spectre de la
guerre sur la guerre sur le sur le
terrain européen et qu'une union
européenne de la défense sur un chemin
long difficile mais un chemin qu'il
faudra prendre avant qu'il ne soit trop
tard au coeur de cette guerre julien
bien sûr il ya les civils notamment ces
mères et leurs enfants qui racontent
leur calvaire depuis un peu plus de
trois semaines maintenant un calvaire à
sous les bombardements avant de fuir le
pays oui c'est une galerie de portraits
extrêmement fort que je vous invite à
lire sur le site du new york times avec
ce titre évocateur je n'ai pas le droit
de pleurer parce que ces femmes qui ont
tout quitté luttent pour leur survie
ainsi que celle de leurs enfants il y a
notamment cette mère journaliste qui
raconte avoir cru que l'armée coréenne
pouvait faire barrage aux chars russes
avant de se résoudre à l'évidence et
donc de quitter sa ville et de quitter
aussi son pays elle nous raconte un
exode sous les balles et notamment cet
épisode extrêmement incroyable au milieu
du chaos avec au moment d'un échange de
tirs en fait sa plus jeune fille qui
éclate de rire une fois que les tirs
sont terminés rires nerveux donc ça
c'est aussi pour faire écho au
traumatisme des enfants et parmi les
rescapés de marioupol julien beaucoup
sont des enfants exfiltré vers des
hôpitaux de l'ouest de l'ukraine oui
notamment dans douze ans je vous renvoie
donc dans un reportage du figaro à
l'hôpital pour enfants de zappos ridja
c'est environ 1 200 km à l'ouest de
mario paul où seulement six enfants ont
pu être transféré ces derniers jours
grâce aux corridors humanitaires enfants
blessés par balles ou par des
projectiles et surtout encore une fois
enfants même s'il recouvre un long terme
leur santé physique qui seront à très
très long terme voire toute leur vie l'a
traumatisée par ce qu'ils ont vu un
témoin mais un témoin un médecin
témoigne par donc au moins 115 enfants
sont morts et 140 ont été blessés depuis
le début du conflit d'après les
autorités ukrainiennes
une guerre qui pourrait aussi julien
avoir des conséquences très graves en
matière de production alimentaire pour
les ukrainiens bien sûr sur le court
terme mais aussi plus largement sur la
demande mondiale imaginez un pays où les
villes et des villages fou face à des
magasins vidés à des coupures d'eau
ajoutez à cela une production à l'école
réduite à néant à cause de la guerre et
vous avez là tous les risques d'une
famine à grande échelle à long terme
explique le wall street journal grandes
terres céréalières surnommé le grenier
de l'europe l'ukraine ne peut plus
plantée de grains de blé 2 pour la
saison prochaine et les conséquences
pourraient être dramatiques pour la
population si le conflit devait perdurer
autre conséquence à l'échelle globale
vous le disiez regarder cette une du
gulf news les gouvernements mondiaux
panique à l'idée d'une potentielle crise
alimentaire mondiale 10% des
exportations de blé vienne d'ukraine le
cren exporte majoritairement vers les
pays du maghreb et du proche-orient dont
on a déjà vu dans ces pays-là des
magasins où il y avait des pénuries sur
ces produits de première nécessité
impact aussi en russie pays donc sujet à
de graves sanctions internationales le
quotidien russe kommersant a constaté de
très longues files d'attentes dans les
épiceries pour obtenir là aussi des
produits de première nécessité quel est
le premier produit utilisé est bien
c'est le sucre les russes se sont rués
là le sucre en dépit des alertes
répétées du gouvernement comme quoi il
n'y aurait pas de pénurie de sucre dans
le pays merci beaucoup julien vous
retrouver aux alentours de 9h20 tout à
l'heure on reviendra aussi sur les
dernières actualités de la campagne pour
la présidentielle ici en france on est à
20 jours du premier tour ce lundi